[Musique]
il n'y aura pas de duel télévisé entre
jean marie le pen est jacques chirac le
président sortant l'a refusée ce qui a
provoqué aussitôt une réaction virulente
de son compétiteur charles s'inviter une
entorse à la coutume républicaine pour
la première fois depuis 1974
le duel cathodique de l'autre deux tours
n'aura pas lieu
ce combat souvent sanctionnés par un ko
le président candidat n'en veut pas la
politique du spectacle
ça n'est pas pour lui question de forme
est question de fond pas plus que je
n'ai accepté dans le passé d'alliance
avec le front national
et ceci quel qu'en soit le prix
politique
pas plus que je ne les accepte et dans
le passé je n'accepterai demain de
débats avec son représentant
je ne peux pas accepter la banalisation
de l'intolérance et de la haine
l'intolérance et la haine pour ligne de
démarcation
voilà les mots du président candidat une
ligne de partage récusé par jean marie
le pen à l'aise aux jeux du cirque et
dans la fosse aux lions c'est une
pitoyable dégonfle had moi je lui
offrais annuel et quand un adversaire
d'un duel est considérée comme s'étant
retiré il est déshonoré sont les règles
de l'honneur une matière que connaît mal
jacques chirac alors duels et non pas
débat décidément politique
les deux capitaines à l'évidence ne
tiennent pas le même cas
[Musique]